but we begin this morning with growing
calls for the resignation of Virginia
Governor Ralph Northam on Friday to
racially insensitive yearbook entries
from North amend medical school days
surfaced one includes a picture the
governor admits he is in it's of a
person in blackface joined by a person
wearing a KKK robe the other lists a
racial slur as one of North American
dates want to see Northam step aside
Kenneth Gregg is here with the details
Kenneth good morning well good morning
to you Anthony since those yearbook
entries surfaced Northam a Democrat
elected in 2017 has issued two apologies
in each he remained committed to
continuing his term as governor but this
morning his support is evaporating I
believe you deserve to hear directly
from me
governor Ralph Northam put out this
video statement hours after releasing a
written apology for this photograph from
his medical school yearbook it shows two
people dressed in black face and a KKK
hood one of them is Northam a second
yearbook entry later surfaced from
Northam steam at Virginia Military
Institute listing his nickname as a
racial slur I cannot change the
decisions I made nor can I undo the harm
my behavior calls then and today but I
accept responsibility for my past
actions and I'm ready to do the hard
work of regaining your trust reaction
was Swift with much of the outrage
coming from Northam
presidential candidates Kamala Harris
Kirsten Gillibrand Elizabeth Warren Cory
Booker and who Leon Castro all called
for Northam did Planned Parenthood the
n-double-a-cp
and the Richmond times-dispatch Northam
was elected in 2017 after a bitter and
racially charged campaign against
Republican Ed Gillespie in one tweet he
criticized Gillespie's rhetoric for
being racist and fear-mongering the med
school yearbook photo was first
published by the right-wing website
big league news and it comes amid
scrutiny of Northam by conservatives
after comments he made about a Virginia
bill expanding access to third trimester
abortions if a mother is in labor I can
tell you exactly what would happen the
infant would be delivered the infant
would be kept comfortable the infant
would be resuscitated if that's what the
mother and the family desired and then a
discussion would ensue between the
physicians and the mothers and
protesters are expected today outside
the Virginia governor's mansion in
Richmond if Northam leaves off as his
lieutenant governor Justin Fairfax would
take over Fairfax is only the second
African American to ever win statewide
office in Virginia and we have not heard
from him yet worth noting Michelle yeah
Doug while there being the first and he
was governor Thank You Kenneth